einen schön guten Abend zu Ihnen Herr
reisn guten Abend liebe Grüße aus Wien
lassen sie uns erstmal mit den aktuellen
Meldungen beginnen Herr Reisner zum
asofschen mehrchauen der Verlust zweier
russischer Flugzeuge sind laut
ukrainischer Luftwaffe der jüngste
Erfolg wie sehr hat das Russland
geschadet ja wir haben hier ganz klar
die Aussage von auch general solusni
dass es gelungen sein soll zumindest
eines dieser beiden Flugzeuge
abzuschießen eine sogenannte A50 dieses
Flugzeug ist deswegen bedeutungsvoll
weil es zur Früherkennung vor allem von
möglichen Zielen auf ukrainischer Seite
für die russische Seite dient es ist
quasi wie eine fliegende radarplattform
zu betrachten und das zweite Flugzeug
ist eine sogenannte il22m eine fliegende
Kommandozentrale nach den jetzt
vorliegenden Berichten soll es so
gewesen sein dass es zumindest mit
bodenluftsystemen der fliegeabwehr oder
möglicherweise auch mit der
luftluftsysteme gelungen ist diese A50
abzuschießen es gibt hier noch keine
offizielle bestät igung des Kremel aber
in den sozialen Netzwerken auch auf
russischer Seite wird dieser Verlust
diskutiert und besprochen das heiß da
dürfte sehr wahrscheinlich passiert sein
obwohl wir noch keine Bilder eines Frags
vorliegen haben anders ist es bei dem
zweiten Flugzeug bei dieser il22m hier
gibt es tatsächlich zumindest zwei
Bilder dieses Heckleitwerk dieses
Flugzeuges zeigen das offensichtlich
durchlöchert worden ist in einer Art und
Weise wie es typisch ist für fliegerbehr
Systeme und damit kann man davon
ausgehen dass es zumindest gelungen ist
dieses Flugzeug zu beschädigen das
Besondere an beiden Systemen ist dass
sie nur in einer begrenzten Stückzahl
verfügbar sind z.B diese A50 hier nimmt
man an dass ca zwei Handvoll verfügbar
sind von denen immer eine Handvoll im
Einsatz ist und rotiert und da bedeutet
natürlich dieser Abschuss sehr wohl eine
signifikante Verringerung der Fähigkeit
na rusischer Seite und sie dürfen nicht
vergessen die Russen sind jetzt
gezwungen bis zur Klärung der Umstände
was hat also diese Ursache des
Abschusses mit sich gebracht gezwungen
ihre Kräfte zurückzuziehen in der Luft
um zu vermeiden dass es zu weiteren
Abschüssen kommt die russische Seite hat
ein narrativ in der Raum gestellt dass
es durch Friendly Fire also durch eigene
Kräfte abgeschossen wäre das scheint
aber eher unwahrscheinlich da beide
Flugzeuge das in einer große
auseinanderliegenden Distanz getroffen
worden sind mm also im Luftraum müssen
Sie wie Sie sagen erstmal die Kräfte
zurückziehen aber am Boden da ist
Angriff angesagt wie man in den letzten
Tagen beobachten konnte und auch
Meldungen aus der vergangenen Nacht dass
es wieder ordentliche Luftangriffe gab
33 Drohnen und zwei Raketen wurden da
auf die Ukraine abgefeuert ähm die
ukrainische Seite beklagt schon seit
längerem dass es an Munition fehlt das
hat Vitali klitschku jetzt auch noch mal
bekräftigt es gibt da enorme Defizite
und er sagt es gebe aktuell einen
wahnsinnsdruck von russischer Seite
trotz ja Verluste und Verschleiß die es
ja bei russischer Seite gibt
beispielsweise eben jetzt mit diesen
zwei Flugzeugen die es jetzt nicht mehr
gibt auf russischer Seite scheint das
ganze ja doch noch zu funktionieren
Kriegsmaterial scheint ausreichend da zu
sein ja das ist das Dilemma wir sehen
also diese Ereignisse und diese Berichte
die zum Teil spektakul re Erfolge mit
sich bringen wie dieser Abschuss von
diesen A50 und man hat den Eindruck dass
es für die ukrainische Seite gut läuft
tatsächlich ist es aber so wenn man ins
Detail geht auf der strategischen
operativ und taktischen Ebene sieht man
dass tatsächlich die Ukraine in der
Defensive ist und Russland in der
Offensive unter anderem ist es darauf
zurückzuführen dass Russland es
geschafft hat vor im letzten Jahr seinen
militärischen industriellen Komplex
anzukurbeln und die munitionsproduktion
signifikant zu erhöhen und zwar jene
Munition die auf den verschiedenen
eingesetzt ist das heißt z.B auf der
strategischen Ebene ist es vor allem der
Einsatz von marsalow Körpern und diesen
von dem Iran gelieferten drohen die
Russland jetzt selbst produziert man
nimmt an dass Russland in der Lage ist
im Monat ca 100 marsflugkörper und
ballistische Raketen zu produzieren und
ca 350 dononen das heißt das sind 450 in
einem Monat verfügbaren Angriffsmittel
die natürlich von ukrainischer Seite
bekämpft werden müssen durch
fliegabwehrsysteme und durch die
Munition dazu auf operativ und taktische
Ebene ist ist aber V allem der Einsatz
der ie der den Ukrain große Probleme
bereitet man nimmt an dass Russland
letztes Jahr C 2 Millionen Stück
Artilleriegranaten vom Kaliber 122 und
122 mm erzeugt hat dazu kamen noch die
Lieferung von einer Million
artillerigranaten aus Nordkorea und das
bedeutet dass jetzt zur Zeit wieder das
Verhältnis pro Tag in etwa ist 2000
Schuss auf ukrainischer Seite zu 10.000
Schuss auf russischer Seite und da sieht
man natürlich dass es hier sich das
Gleichgewicht zu Ungunsten der Ukraine
entwickelt wenn die Ukraine nicht weiter
massiv unterstützt wird um hier entgegen
gehalten zu können t und da bleibt da
kommt direkt auch die erste Frage von
unserem Zuschauer space Cowboy auf
Youtube welche Waffensysteme könnten die
Länder der EU kurzfristig an die Ukraine
liefern was ist da noch machbar gibt es
einen mittelfristigen Plan die Ukraine
nachhaltig zu unterstützen was glauben
Sie dazu muss man sich ja ansehen wie
die Strategie der Ukraine im Moment sich
darstellt und die Ukraine hat zu Ende
letzten Jahres Grund getan dass sie
quasi von der Offensive in die Defensive
gehen möchte Defensive bedeutet das
Halten des gewohnenen G ländes und vor
allem das konsolidierens in der Tiefe
des Landes das heißt der Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur der Schutz des
Ukrainisch militärisch industriellen
komplexes um im Laufe dieses Jahres
quasi in der Lage zu sein eigene
Rüstungsproduktion wieder hochzufahren
und damit sind wir bei entsprechend
prioritätenreihung und das bedeutet am
Beginn vor allem das Senden von weiteren
fliegerbesystemen von weiteren
fliegerbebatterien ob das jetzt IRS oder
Pot oder ähnliches ist und deprechend
Munition damit dieses erste strategische
Ziel erreicht werden kann in weiterer
Folge dann alle jene System die es auch
für die Ukraine möglich machen die
Russen an empfindlichen Stellen zu
treffen das heißt es werden bodenboden
oder luftbodensysteme mit entsprechender
Reichweite mit dem man dann in der Lage
ist z.B logistikpunkte der russischen
Armee oder auch Kommandostrukturen
anzugreifen der Westen hat ja zumindest
heute Nachmittag eine Antwort schon mal
rausgeschickt das kam als einmeldung die
NATO plant im Februar ja das größte
Manöver seit dem Kalten Krieg 90.000
Soldaten sollen dann da im Einsatz sein
man will ja den Worst Case sage ich mal
Proben sofern Russland eventuell
natoterritorium angreift wie man sich da
verteidigt und welcher Antwort man da
entgegensetzt heißt es man will man
wolle damit Putin abschrecken da stellt
sich dann natürlich die Frage wenn solch
ein Szenario eintritt oder wenn jetzt
erstmal das ganze geprobt wird
beeindruckt das Putin oder ist es gar
abschreckend für
ihn ja diese Übung ist natürlich ein
wichtiges Zeichen der natuto gegenüber
Russland um Russland zu verstehen zu
geben dass man nicht bereit ist zu
tolerieren dass es tatsächlich zu eine
ang natoterritorium kommen würde im
Wesentlichen sind hier vier Faktoren die
relevant sind einerseits der Faktor
Kraft man sieht hier die Menge von
90.000 Allierten Soldaten zusammen also
sehr hohe Zahl die quasi über Europa
verteilt eingesetzt werden und man zeigt
auch dass man quasi diesen Raum vom
norduropa bis in den Süden hinunter
beherrschen kann bzw dass es möglich ist
aus den USA zusätzliche Kräfte
heranzuführen und das und damit sind wir
beim Faktor ze das dritten Faktor in
sehr kurzer und relevanter Zeit das ist
man ist verlegefähig man kann also
relativ rasch auch reagieren für den
Fall dass Russland etwas unternimmt und
der vierte das vierte Element ist
natürlich der Faktor Information hier
geht's vor allem ganz klar darum auch im
Informationsraum dominant aufzutreten
diesen Raum nicht der russischen Seite
zu überlassen sondern auch zu zeigen und
auch den europäischen Bevölkerung und
den NATO Mitgliedern zu zeigen wir sind
in der Lage in kurzer Zeit massive
Kräfte aufzubieten um hier wasasi auch
unseren Bündnispartner beizustehen im
Fall eines Angriffes wir wollen heute
abends bei zeitfte live in die einzelnen
Brennpunkte in die Region schauen und
wollen mal im Süden anfangen herreisen
schauen wir nach her zunächst die Region
war russisch besetzt wurde vor einem
Jahr von der Ukraine
wieder befreit und ist scheinbar nun ein
Ort den die Russen verstärkt wieder
angreifen da ist in dieser Woche erst
wurden da wieder zahlreiche Wohngebäude
bei Luftangriffen zerstört hat man
gelesen was für eine Strategie verfolgt
Putin denn da
jetzt ja das Süden der Front da hat im
Wesentlichen zwei Bereiche die für die
Russen interessant sind einerseits ist
es das Industriezentrum kerson wo es es
natürlich einige Betriebe gibt die für
die Rüstung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte produzieren und hier
versucht man ganz gezielt mit der
marschflohkörpern mit ballistischen
Raketen mit iranischen Drohnen diese
Ziele zu treffen und dabei der Abwehr
von diesen einfliegenden marchflugagern
kommt es dann zu Abschüssen wo zum Teil
auch diese trümer in den bewohnten
Gebieten runtergehen oder aufgrund einer
ungenauen eines ungenauen Einsatzes der
russischen Raketen dass diese quas in
den Wohngebieten herunterkommen das ist
der eine Versuch das ist auch ähnlich in
hakiv oder auch in anderen Städten wie
z.B in Kiev vor allem am Ostufer des
znepers das zweite was im Süden
interessant ist ist natürlich die
Situation in dem Brückenkopf bei grinki
tatsächlich gibt es eigentlich hier vier
Brückenköpfe entlang des nepers und die
Situation ist die dass die Ukraine hier
versucht vor allem auch zu zeigen dass
es ihr möglich ist auch Momentum
aufrechtzuhalten durch den Einsatz ihrer
Kräfte sind hier vier Brigaden der
ukrainischen Marines die eingesetzt sind
die quasi hier rotieren und dort
eingesetzt sind das Dilemma besteht
darin dass die Witterungsverhältnisse
mittlerweile sehr prekär sind es ist so
dass der T beginnt zuzufrieren in dem
Sumpfgebiet auch die kleinen Fluss fe
frieren zu es ist kaum mehr möglich
diese Kräfte zu versorgen und damit
spitzt sich die Situation zu und
Russland ist momentan gerade dabei
krinki langsam wieder zurückzuobern und
wir sehen jetzt natürlich dass es quasi
hier dieser Kampf un dies
mitterungsbedingungen sehr schwierig ist
und dass hier die Ukraine gezwungen ist
die logistische Versorgung so gut wie
möglich aufrechtzuhalten wenn Sie diesen
Brückenkopf halten möchte und nicht
aufgeben möchte mhm da stehen die
Zeichen scheinbar auf Angriff Jan fragt
wie realistisch ist es dass Russland
sich aus der Ukraine zurückzieht bei
diesen Bildern wohl er un wahrcheinlich
oder das ist korrekt wenn auch hier man
sich anhört was ukrainische offizielle
sagen nehmen wir nur die Zahl der
verfügbaren Kräfte auf russischer Seite
man geht davon aus dass Russland ca 462
000 Soldaten in der Ukraine im Einsatz
hat dazu kommen noch 55 Soldaten der
rosgardia also der Besatzungstruppen man
immt an dass Russland in der Lage ist
pro Tag zwischen 1000 und 1100 neu
Rekruten qu sie die als
vertragsbedienstet übernommen werden in
die Streitkräfte zu übernehmen das
gleicht in jeden Fall die Verluste aus
die auchon von ukrainischer Seite
angegeben werden und das bedeutet dass
man eigentlich um das doppelter wenn ich
Zweieinhalbfache mehr an Kräften
verfügbar hat als am Beginn des Krieges
und Russland wie sie völlig richtig
gesagt haben ist im Angriffsmodus wir
haben jetzt den zweiten Winter die
zweite Winteroffensive die Russen
versuchen an verschiedenen Stellen an
vielen Stellen gleichzeitig anzugreifen
Rücken Meter für Meter vor das Ziel ist
es aber vor allem die Ukraine zu zwingen
ihre kostbaren Reserven auszuspielen und
einzusetzen und die Absicht der Russen
ist es quasi soweit weiterzumachen bis
aus ihrer Sicht man quasi die Ukrain so
in die Defensive gezwungen hat dass es
möglicherweise zu dem massiven
Durchbruch kommt der sich aber momentan
auf keinen Fall abzeichnet